let's say that you wanted to build a
better i'll give you i'll give you an
example of breaking a good hat or
building a good habit and breaking a bad
one so one of the laws is to make it
obvious and this largely comes down to
like what we're exposed to each year
each day and minimalism and simplicity
plays a big role in this um in the book
i call it environment design that's
basically the strategy so for a long
time i realized that i brushed my teeth
twice a day but i didn't floss
consistently and when i looked at that
habit one of the reasons that i wasn't
flossing consistently is because the
floss was hidden in the drawer in the
bathroom so i just wouldn't see it you
know like i wouldn't open up the drawer
and remember
so i bought a little bowl and got some
of the pre-made flossers and put them in
the bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now i brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all i needed to do
to build the habit of flossing every day
on the other side let's say you know a
lot of people feel like they spend too
much time watching tv or playing video
games or just looking at a screen
but if you walk into pretty much any
living room where do all the couches and
chairs face they all face the television
so it's like what is that room designed
to get you to do it's designed to get
you to watch tv
so there are a variety of uh
levels to this you could for example
take the remote and take it off of the
coffee table and put it inside a drawer
or you could take the television and put
it inside like a wall unit or a cabinet
so you don't see it
you could also increase the friction of
the task so you could like take the
batteries out of the remote
after each use and then you know it's an
extra five or ten seconds put it in
maybe that's just enough time if you
think do i really want to watch
something or am i just doing this
mindlessly
you could
unplug the tv after each individual use
and then only plug it in if you can say
the name of the show you want to watch
so you can't like mindlessly browse on
netflix
and i mean if you really wanted to be
extreme about it you could take the tv
off the wall
put it in the closet and then only take
it out when you really wanted to watch
something but the point here and this is
kind of the the principle of environment
design in general which is
you want to put fewer steps between you
and the good behaviors and more steps
between you and the bad ones and imagine
the cumulative impact of living an
environment that exposes you to the cues
of your positive habits and reduces the
cues of your negative habits it's kind
of like you're just gently being nudged
in the right direction each day and
that's just one of the of the ways that
you can sort of design a system that
leads you into better habits
need motivation what the top 10 we
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best james clear
and my take on his top 10 rules to
success
enjoy
rule number two don't get trapped in
motion just take someone who's trying to
get in shape i mean people will
what kind of protein powder should i get
what knee sleeves do i need what are the
best uh weightlifting shoes and all that
stuff is like the last two percent of
difference that it's mostly like don't
miss workouts and get your reps in this
is what in the book i call the
difference between motion and action
uh action can actually deliver a result
uh but motion
is related to that but never will um you
know like
going to the gym and talking to a
personal trainer about signing up that's
fine that's related to getting in shape
but it doesn't matter how many times you
talk to a personal trainer you're never
going to get in shape whereas like doing
10 squats that actually can do something
it's like talking to the trainer's
motion doing squats as action yeah
and yeah i think a lot of times people
get trapped in motion they get trapped
in analysis paralysis
because it uh is a way to feel like
you're making progress without running
the risk of failure rule number three
avoid distraction every day i try to
leave my phone in another room outside
of my office at least until lunch
because then i get like a four hour
block of time in the morning where i can
just work without any distraction yeah
and um it's funny how quickly you don't
like if my phone was on me in the
morning i would check it like you know
every five minutes or whatever but when
it's out of the room i don't even find
myself wanting to i never walk up the
stairs to go check it even though it's
only 30 seconds away wow so it's it's
interesting how um
little we actually want to do these
things but we just do them all the time
because they're obvious and easy and i
think the key is to invert that take the
things that are the bad habits the
distractions the procrastinations the
unproductive uses of time and make them
more invisible reduce exposure and less
less easy to do and take the things that
are good habits and make it the
equivalent of having your phone on you
all the time right make it right in
front of you make it obvious make it
easy make it um you know frictionless
rule number four build one habit at a
time what really changes your your
outcomes or what really moves your life
in a positive direction is not a single
like one percent change or a single uh
little habit it's a collection of them
all organized towards the same like
overall goal or overall outcome so you
know sometimes people will
they get like a you know fitbit and they
start
they get a fitbit and they start walking
ten thousand steps a day or something
like that and then they get frustrated
after three months because they haven't
seen this change in the mirror or this
change on the scale or whatever but it's
like well that's good but that's just
one habit related to your health you
don't need um you don't need a single
little habit you need like a thousand of
them and once you kind of build this
collection of them all moving you in the
same direction it's kind of like each
one adds a little grain of sand to the
side of the scale and eventually you tip
the scales in your favor and i think
that's another reason to start with one
habit at a time is that
you naturally sort of pick up other
behaviors that are related to the
overall thing that you're working on in
the moment and
and that helps to keep you focused
rather than trying to do two or three
things then you get scattered
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five create
satisfaction we interpret the stimuli
and the data the uh cues in our life
differently based on what our viewpoint
is at that time based on what our
personality or our sorry not our
personality our personal viewpoint is
based on what you believe your
self-image so
you know i mean you see this all the
time with politics you have the same
news story that runs on the tv but then
a liberal and a conservative interpret
that data in completely different ways
and it's because of
what's getting echoed back to them
because of how they see themselves
because of what filter they're running
that data through and the same thing is
true if we're talking about weight loss
or whatever else you know if like you
see a particular number on the scale and
the thing that's being echoed back to
you is i want to lose 20 pounds and feel
great then suddenly you don't feel good
about that number if the same thing if
the thing that's getting echoed back to
you is
i've stuck to workouts for seven days in
a row and i feel more energetic and
healthy then you see the number in a
totally different way same number uh
just different interpretation so
i think it it's important uh but it's
not the whole story um and some of the
the things that also influence things
are you know like what we talked about
making things obvious and making them
easy
but making it satisfying the which is
the fourth kind of major lever that i
talk about in the book
that's crucial for getting people to
come back
and that can come in many different
forms
there's a so i guess i'll just lay the
context for this real quick there
this is really interesting to look at
with a lot of products um so
chewing gum is a good example for many
years for hundreds of years chewing gum
was around but it was like kind of this
bland resin it was just chewy but it
wasn't tasty and wrigley launched in
like 1880 1890 and they came out with
juicy fruit and spearmint and double
mint and suddenly gum was chewy and it
had this immediate flavor there was like
this immediate reward to chewing it and
it took off they became the biggest
chewing gum chewing gum company in the
world
and today many companies are doing the
same kind of thing where they're trying
to layer in a little bit of extra
satisfaction with the product so a
couple years ago bmw came out with a car
that when you press on the accelerator
it'll pipe extra engine growl through
the stereo in the in the car so it's
like more satisfying to step on the gas
ford just came up with another one where
they uh they the engine noise is still
there but they have this valve that
it'll only open and let the engine noise
into the car interior um and pass all
the sound proofing if you really slam on
the gas and like you know rev the rpms
up but if you just drive like normal
it'll keep it soft and quiet um and so
the uh the point there is that all of
those uh products cars or chewing gum
and many others they find ways to layer
immediate satisfaction into the
experience and when you do that people
want to repeat it more
anytime you have some kind of enjoyment
or a satisfying ending to a behavior
it's like this positive signal in your
brain that says hey that felt good you
should do this again next time and
that's what really gets a habit to stick
all the other stuff that we talked about
making habits attractive making them
more obvious make it more convenient to
do that gets a habit to start the first
time or makes it easier for you to do it
right then but the only reason you come
back to it is because it's satisfying
and it's really about the speed of the
satisfaction this is something i call
the cardinal rule of behavior change
which is behaviors that are immediately
rewarded get repeated and behaviors that
are immediately punished get avoided and
the more that you can have that positive
emotional feeling right away the more
reason you have to come back to a habit
in the future rule number six embody
progress if you were coaching someone
who said i have no clue what i'm
supposed to do with my life
um i'm lost i have all these bad habits
i smoke i drink i eat donuts every day
i have no job
my room is sloppy
and i'm just depressed
what would you say to them to get
started with changing their life around
in the form of better habits well you
just need to pick one thing first of all
i think that i just mentioned a few
minutes ago um one of the most powerful
forms of motivation is progress so
seeing some progress i mean it could be
as simple as make your bed each day
right like but just doing that embodying
the identity of someone who's getting
better who's making progress just pick
one thing
and use that as
this is true i mean louis this is
something you've probably seen with a
lot of people that you've talked to but
habits are the foundation for mastery
so if you you know say take a take a
sport like basketball um you need to be
able to dribble with both hands without
thinking before you can worry about
what
strategy you're running on offense or
what kind of you know strategic play
you're going to run or what your
defensive scheme is or all this other
stuff right like you need to automate
the fundamentals of the craft before you
can worry about the next level of
performance
same thing is true for chess you know
like you need to know how the chess
pieces move automatically without
thinking about it before you can get
into all right what is the strategy
going to do and i'm going to do this and
they're going to do that
and so i think this is true not just at
the peak levels of performance that you
integrate these habits and use habits as
the foundation for the next level
performance but also true when you're
getting started just build one small
thing carve out a one percent change a
one percent improvement and use that as
a stepping stone to the next
level rule number seven align goals with
identity true behavior change is really
identity change um because you're you're
not really looking to go from the type
of person who doesn't run to the type of
person who can run a 5k that's fine
that's good it's the outcome but the
goal is not to run a marathon the goal
is to become a runner the goal is not to
write a book the goal is to become a
writer and once you identify as that
type of person
in a sense you're not even really
pursuing behavior change anymore you're
just acting in alignment with the type
of person that you already believe that
you are right it's like one thing to say
i want this it's something different to
say i am this rule number eight make
decisive moments in my personal life
you know like there's a moment around 5
15 each night my wife gets home from
work and either we change into our
workout clothes and we go to the gym or
we don't change into our workout clothes
and we watch you know reruns of the
office in order to take out or whatever
and really the next two hours are kind
of determined by
that decisive moment of whether we
change into our workout clothes or not
if we change it close then like
everything else is going to happen
automatically we're going to drive to
the gym i'll get it under the bar i'll
do it's already pre-decided basically
so
one of the realizations of this and it
comes back to your kind of central
question of what you know what are the
most important habits to build or are
there ones that ripple into other areas
of life
if you can just master maybe
five or ten decisive moments throughout
the day these little kind of two-minute
chunks that determine the next block of
time
you really only have to focus your
attention and energy on that and the the
the rest of it kind of comes easily you
don't have to do that much uh if you can
master the right moments it's kind of
like judo for your personal habits you
know you apply the pressure in the right
place and everything else kind of falls
in line rule number nine establish a
habit if your expectations are sky high
um you know like have you set i have a
friend who's a writer and he his goal is
to write one sentence every day um and
it sounds absurd but
if you set the expectation that low then
he can feel successful pretty much every
day he always can feel satisfied by
sticking to the habit which gives him a
reason to come back again the next day
and sometimes he writes a full page and
sometimes it's just a sentence but um if
he had set a goal of writing a thousand
words a day there would be some days
where he couldn't do that and then
suddenly he's feeling bad about that
like what if he wrote one sentence that
day he would feel bad about it even
though
he still wrote that day but it's just
because of his expectation so there's a
little bit of like mental play that's
going on there in how we kind of we
sabotage ourselves by setting the bar so
high that's especially true in the
beginning i think that it becomes less
true for maybe the one or two areas
where you really want to be a master in
life like if something's really
important to you and you want peak
performance you want to be a
professional athlete you want to be
you know among the best authors or
something like that then maybe
your strategy needs to change but for
most people most of the time the
strategy is probably better to set the
bar low find a way to be satisfied and
show up each day and then once you've
built the habit then you optimize from
there this is um
i had a reader who ended up losing over
100 pounds and one of the things that he
did was he went to the gym um
but he wasn't allowed to stay for longer
than five minutes and so it sounds so
weird because it's a complete opposite
of what most people do to build a habit
but he what he was doing was he was
mastering the art of showing up um and
so
for six weeks he went to the gym he'd go
in do like half an exercise and then
five minutes would be up and go home
and eventually got to the point where
he's like you know i'm coming here all
the time i kind of feel like staying
longer right but that's that's the
opposite of the person who takes the
intermediate crossfit class and like
kills themselves for three weeks and
then it feels totally fried and you know
gives up and then three months later
they're like oh i got to get back in
shape
and so
a habit must be established before it
can be improved right often we optimize
for the finish line we think about the
outcome that we want we think about like
oh i want to lose 20 pounds or i want to
earn six figures this year whatever the
the thing is
but instead if you just focus on the
first two minutes of the behavior in
this guy's case the first five minutes
of the behavior and you optimize for the
starting line you master the art of
showing up but then you have options
then you can you actually have something
that you can improve if you're not the
type of person who shows up at the gym
even if it's just for five minutes
it doesn't even matter what your ideal
workout plan is or whatever like you
can't do anything because you're not
there
and so
um in that sense i think that it's often
helpful for people especially in the
beginning to scale a habit down to the
first two minutes master the art of
showing up and then once you're the type
of person who does it every day figure
out a way to improve and rule number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is resist temptation how
much willpower do we have
so
you hear this a lot i mean it's very
common especially in self-help
motivation self-improvement you need to
be motivated you have to have willpower
grit and perseverance are huge and
important and it's not that those
qualities are not important it's just
that the way to develop them is
different than what most people think so
most people think i need willpower so i
should just try harder
there's an interesting body of research
i mentioned it in the book i think it's
in chapter 7 on self-control and
willpower which is that the people who
appear to have the greatest self-control
actually are just tempted the least so
they face temptations less frequently
and therefore have the reserves and the
resources to resist it when it
occasionally comes up
and i think that this is actually like
the lever to pull or the pressure point
to push on is that the way to get better
willpower is to design an environment
that tempts you less not to say let me
just try harder now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated the science says you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through on your goals that's not good
enough no not for you believe nation we
got to do something but when you write
it down and you create a specific plan
of action for the next week that number
jumps to 91 chance of you following
through and when you commit to somebody
else like leaving a comment on this
video it jumps to 95 you need to follow
through on your goals so what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your specific plan of action for the
next week put it down in the comments
below so i can celebrate you how do i
become the type of person who doesn't
miss workouts and
that's another reason i like small
habits because if you have a really busy
day and things are crazy and all you can
do is five push-ups if you're oriented
around the result around the outcome
it's easy to dismiss that it's like why
would i even bother doing five push-ups
it's not gonna get me in shape but some
days it's not about the result of the
training some days it's about
reinforcing being that type of person
you know like yes life was crazy and
things were really busy today and the
best i could do was getting five
push-ups in but i'm still the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts even
when it's not ideal right and in the
long run that can count for a lot which
is the kind of twisted thing about small
habits which is that even though they're
small they can still be meaningful and
if they're meaningful they actually are
big one of the phrases i use i have this
in the book is that habits are the
compound interest of self-improvement so
it's like the same way that
compound interest you know accrues
through finance your the effects of your
habits multiply over time and so often
these choices that you make these little
one percent improvements for you or
against you each day and they're very
easy to overlook on a daily basis right
like what what really is the difference
between eating a burger and fries or a
salad and chicken for lunch you don't
really feel a lot better yeah right yeah
it tastes amazing
that's actually a crucial point that i
cover in the book which is that habits
that are immediately satisfying are more
likely to be repeated and so pretty much
any behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time right like if you eat a
doughnut right now it's tasty and it
should be good but in the long run you
gain weight and so the the immediate
outcome is favorable the long-term
outcome is unfavorable with good habits
it's often the reverse right like you go
to the gym right now and it takes effort
you sweat you have to work hard to
sacrifice your time for netflix and
chill to go train the immediate outcome
is unfavorable but the ultimate outcome
you're in shape and
you know a year or month or whatever
right it's favorable and so the
challenge for building good habits and
breaking bad ones is often finding a way
to pull the long-term consequences of
your bad habits into the immediate
moment so you feel a little bit of the
pain right now and want to avoid it and
the long-term rewards of your good
habits into the immediate moment so you
have a reason to repeat it again in the
future each behavior casts a vote for
the type of person that you want to
become and if you cast enough votes for
that type of identity you start to
believe that about yourself right like
if you you go to church for 20 years you
believe that you're religious you study
spanish every tuesday for 30 minutes you
believe that you are studious
so in that way your habits provide
evidence of your desired identity and i
think that that is
probably the ultimate reason that habits
are so important it's true like habits
can help you earn more money or be more
productive or lose weight
and all that stuff is great
but in addition to the external results
that habits provide they also shape your
sense of self they like are the at the
engine or the avenue through which you
learn to believe things about yourself
like sometimes people will say stuff
like
fake it till you make it but fake it
till you make it is asking yourself to
believe something without evidence for
it and you can do that for a little
while you could do it for day or week
but eventually i mean there's a word for
beliefs that don't have evidence behind
them it's delusion right and if you're
deluding yourself then eventually you
give up on that but the power of doing a
better habit each day or casting a
little vote for that type of person is
that now you have evidence to root your
belief in yeah so now i've done six
months yeah right like i mean now you
have a lot of evidence that you're a
podcaster or a good interviewer you know
like you do this over and over again
each time you cast a vote for believing
that about yourself and you don't just
you aren't delusionally believing that
you're a good interviewer it's because
you've shown up and done it hundreds of
times right um and so i think that
that's true for any habit large or small
that they provide evidence of the
desired identity or the the type of
person that you are there's this
professor at the university of florida
he's retired now he was a photography
professor his name is jerry ulsman
and
at the beginning of the semester he
would have this film photography class
and bring the class in and he would
split them into two groups he said
everybody on this side of the room
you're going to be graded on the
quantity of work that you do this
semester and everybody on this side of
the room you're going to be graded on
the quality of work that you do this
semester and he's further explained it
by saying that
for your film photography you're going
to be responsible for having 100
pictures if you do 100 photos over the
course of the semester that'll be a if
you do 90 it'll be a b if you do 80
it'll be c and so on so it's quantity
for this group you only have to produce
one photo but it has to be the most
perfect photo that you can make the best
photo that you can make
an interesting and interesting thing
happened at the end of the term all the
best grades came from the quantity group
not from the quality group
and what ended up happening was that
while people were busy experimenting
making mistakes learning how to you know
play with composition and so on they
would come across a really great photo
and while the quality group was busy
theorizing about what perfection would
look like and how to take the perfect
photo and not actually honing their
skills they ended up only making
something mediocre or average
and
the important insight here especially
for habits is that in the beginning the
most important thing is just to shut up
and put your reps in just make sure that
you hone the skill right and you can
start to think of it the way that i like
to think of it is that any outcome that
you wish to achieve is just a point
along the spectrum of repetitions so if
you have few reps to more reps and you
can imagine an easy goal moderate goal a
hard goal
the more reps that you put in the more
that you more likely you are to achieve
that goal so maybe point a is you know
let's take fitness squatting 100 pounds
point b is squatting 200 point c is
quoting 300. maybe you need to put in
100 reps or a thousand reps to get to
point a maybe it's 5 thousand to get to
point b maybe it was ten thousand to get
the point to see
occasionally and this is true for
everybody if you live long enough life
will come for you at some point right
like something's going to happen um so
occasionally life will stress you
but when life doesn't challenge you i
think it's important to challenge
yourself because otherwise you're just
living in this optimal environment air
conditioning and you know everything
else is super easy you can get all the
information in the world at your
fingertips you never have to like if you
think about how crazy just eating is in
the modern world so previously when we
lived in tribes you you had to expend
energy to get calories
at a minimum you were foraging for
berries but otherwise you probably had
to like run something down and kill it
or part of a group hunt or all kinds of
other things
now you can get calories without
expending any all you have to do is just
tap like uber eats on your phone or
something it'll show up at your door um
and you can just sit on the couch which
is of course like a recipe for uh poor
health but also just it's the game has
completely changed now we've
transcended a lot of our evolutionary
programming and natural
situations
and so you need to be careful about
designing that to serve you rather than
to work against you because it can very
easily nudge you in the other direction
i think there are a few core habits that
are going to serve everybody and
certainly serve me well so exercise is a
huge one um i don't do it daily but i
exercise i train four times a week yeah
and i feel like if i didn't exercise i
don't know that i would be an
entrepreneur like i don't know if i
could handle the psychological roller
coaster without the physical outlet yeah
the release the
you probably feel that as like an
athlete too you know like for
being an athlete for so many years i
feel like i need to push myself
physically in addition to mentally it is
just mental it doesn't do it for me i
need to have a physical outlet so
exercise exercises one the other the
ultimate meta habit is reading because
if you build a habit of reading you can
solve pretty much any other problem you
know you want to learn how to be a
better podcaster you can read about that
you want to learn how to meditate you
can read about that you want to learn
how to make more money you can read
about that um and so what you need is to
develop a habit of reading and then
whatever problem you're facing at the
time you can you have a method for
solving that one of my favorite studies
is about exercise and they had three
cohorts in this study so they have first
cohort they said i just want you to
track how often you work out over the
next few weeks right so that's the the
standard cohort the control group
second group is that we want to track
often you exercise we're also going to
give you a motivation motivational
speech presentation talk about the
benefits of heart health why habits are
good for you and so on so this is the
motivated group right
the third group they got the same
presentation so they're equally
motivated and then they did one thing
differently and that one thing was they
filled out this sentence it said during
the next week i will partake in at least
20 minutes of vigorous exercise on this
day in this time at this time in this
place right they specifically stated
their intention to implement the
behavior so implementation intention
here's what happened
first group one out of three of them
worked out second group motivation did
nothing as soon as they left the
researchers facility the next day they
weren't motivated it's like reading a
book or watching youtube or listening to
a motivational speaker and then you
forget all about it 20 minutes later
but the third group the group that has a
specific plan for how they were going to
implement the behavior nine out of 10 of
them worked out so you can increase your
odds of success two to three x just by
having a specific plan and this is the
insight many people think that they lack
motivation when what they really lack is
clarity
they think that they need to get more
motivated that they need willpower in
order to execute on a habit if i just
felt like writing if i just felt like
meditating i felt like working out then
i would do it but in fact they don't
have a plan for it so they wake up each
day thinking i wonder if i'll feel
motivated to write today i wonder if
i'll feel motivated to work out today
but instead you can take the decision
making out of it by explicitly stating
when where and how you want to implement
the habit it sounds easy to say let's
just start a plan let's you know write
down exactly what you should do and then
maybe you'll follow through on it but of
course we all know that there are
challenges that arise it's not quite
that easy so here's a little strategy
that i like to use to make sure you can
come up with a better plan of action and
it's called a failure pre-mortem so the
way that it works is you think about the
habit the project the goal whatever the
most important thing is that you want to
work on and i want you to imagine fast
forward six months from now you failed
and then tell the story of why you
failed what happened what challenges did
you encounter what was it that took you
off course um
when i do this with businesses sometimes
we call it the kill the company exercise
because everybody just sits around
thinks about ways to kill the company in
the next six months
and
once you have all that stuff laid out on
the table in front of you you can start
to make better choices about how to
develop a plan you can start to have if
then plans so not only
do i want to exercise for 20 minutes on
monday at 5 p.m but also if i do not
exercise because i have to take my kid
to practice or whatever then it's
tuesday morning at 7 am i will go in
right you can have ways to adjust for
these challenges i think we actually
have like three options for breaking bad
habits so the first option is to reduce
exposure um
so something like you know if you want
to stop spending so much money on
electronics then don't follow all the
latest tech review blogs you know like
or if you want to lose weight don't
follow a bunch of food bloggers on
instagram you're constantly being
triggered by that and having to like
overcome the problems
now that doesn't always work but if you
can cut a habit off at the source then a
lot of the time like the craving won't
arise uh naturally so in atomic habits
in the book i talk a little bit about
this woman who she smoked while she was
in college and she would always smoke
while riding horses with a friend
and so eventually at some point she quit
smoking and she also stopped you know
like seeing that friend and graduated
from college and so on wasn't riding
horses and then like 10 years later she
got back on a horse for the first time
and suddenly craved a cigarette and
she was like what is going on here and
it's your habits are often tied to a
context they're tied to a situation or
some kind of cue and so if you can
reduce exposure to that cue then in many
cases the craving won't arise so that's
the first option for breaking bad habit
the second option which kind of sucks
but is like to sit with the craving long
enough to like let this wave a desire
ride itself out and so you basically
just resist temptation um it's possible
it's easier if um if your hand is forced
if you use what i call a commitment
device so
a brief story real quick victor hugo um
famous author who wrote like hunchback
notre dame and a bunch of other things
well
when he got the book deal for hunchback
of notre dame he just procrastinated for
like a year he hosts a bunch of house
parties has friends over he went
traveling for a little while
yeah
he got the book deal he did nothing no
work um and eventually his publisher got
pissed off they were like you know can
you please like actually work on this
and so they set this ultimatum for him
and they said uh
we're gonna we're gonna cancel the book
in six months if you don't have it done
by then and so he um
he got his assistant to come in put all
his clothes into a chest and they locked
him up and took him out of the house and
the only thing he was left with was like
this the shawl this like large robe
so basically he had no clothes that were
suitable for hosting guests or for
leaving the house or like going on trips
or anything else so more or less put
himself on house arrest
and what ended up happening was each
time procrastination arose he was able
to kind of sit with that feeling and let
it ride because he didn't really have
many other options and then get back to
work on the book and it ended up working
he got the book done like two weeks
early but things like that where you can
lock in your future action and it
becomes really hard to go to your
friend's party or go out to you know
travel to a different place or whatever
just because you don't have the option
if you can increase the friction then
sometimes you can sit with the craving
of a bad habit and let it ride out so
that's your second choice and then the
third choice is the one that you just
mentioned which is you take
the solution that the bad habit is
providing the way that it's serving you
and you find a new behavior that
delivers that same outcome what makes
you an expert on habits oh man based on
lots of other people that are talking
about habits i think that and i've said
this many times before i'm just going
through this with everybody else
i consider my readers my peers in the
sense that we're all just trying things
out the only difference is i write about
what i learn and share it each week and
but we're all just learning along the
way um early on i had a feeling like
that i was like who am i to you know i'm
just a guy who might write about this
and i had a friend tell me the way you
develop expertise is by writing about it
every week so i wrote a new article
about habits every monday and thursday
for three years and that was how i
developed the expertise on the topic by
writing about it i did research
you said here's what i found here's what
i tried here's what worked what didn't
work it's a combination of me reading
the scientific literature and reading
the research and then trying to distill
practical insights from that and testing
things out in my own life as a
weightlifter a travel photographer a
writer an entrepreneur and seeing what
that looks like and then the two
together i think you need both like i
don't want to be
some new age version of an academic
who's in an ivory tower just like
theorizing about ideas is different what
it looks like to put ideas into practice
right like imagine you're a peak
performance coach and you show up to
coach like an mba team these guys are
like dude you need to step on the court
if you know it right to see what it's
actually like you don't have to be the
victim of your environment you can also
be the architect of it you can decide to
design something to make your good
behaviors easier and your bad behaviors
harder so
when it comes to habits if you want to
practice your guitar more frequently put
it right in the middle of your living
room so you run across all the time if
you want to read more when you make your
bed in the morning take the book you
want to read put it on top of the pillow
when you come back that night pick it up
read a few pages go to sleep
for me i uh i used to buy apples all the
time and then i would put them in the
crisper at the bottom of the fridge and
they would sit there for three weeks and
go bad and i'd finally open it up and
see them again and get mad and then
eventually i bought a bowl and put it
right in the middle of the counter and
so then when i buy apples i put them
there i see them every day and now i eat
them all the time
many of our desires are simply shaped
because we have an environment that
shapes us in that way
so the moral of the story is i've never
seen someone stick to positive habits in
a consistent fashion in a negative
environment maybe you can overpower once
or twice maybe you can have the
willpower to do the right thing on one
day but if you're constantly fighting
against those forces it's going to be
very hard to follow through most people
are familiar with the story of the good
samaritans stopping along the side of
the road to help help a fallen person
help someone in need well princeton
their theology school decided to run
this uh experiment they brought in a
bunch of theology students they said all
right we're all familiar with the story
of the good samaritan we're going to
break you up into groups and you're
going to go teach in different rooms
across campus you're going to teach this
story and so they started talking about
you know how they were going to deliver
the presentation and so on they had a
couple different cohorts the one cohort
they said all right just go ahead and
you know go off and uh and deliver the
presentation so they went off to their
rooms
the second one though they did something
interesting they sent the group off but
on their way to the well they sent the
group off and they said by the way we're
running a little bit behind right you
don't have very long to get there it
takes about 10 minutes you only got five
so we kind of need to hurry um you're
probably already going to be late so
they're in a rush they know they're
going to go give this presentation on
the way they planted an actor on the uh
on the campus and this actor
is laying on the ground hurt moaning in
pain and so they scream twice and then
they cry out
and every single group
went right past the person in need to go
give a presentation about helping a
person in need
right the one person even stepped over
the guy who was in pain in order to get
there now
the point of this and what i'd like to
start talking about now is the danger of
being goal focused and goal-oriented
these people had a goal right to deliver
a presentation and they were so
one-sided so narrow-minded so focused on
that goal that they miss the bigger
picture and the perspective of what they
should have been doing in the first
place
and i think that this can be a danger of
goals often and so instead
i would like to encourage us to focus on
systems systems rather than goals here
are some examples if you're a coach your
goal is to win a championship but your
system is what your team does at
practice each day
if you're a writer your goal might be to
write a book maybe even write a
best-selling book but your system is how
you write each week the schedule that
you follow
if you're an entrepreneur your goal
could be to build a million dollar
business or a 10 million dollar business
but the system is the sales and
marketing process that you have the
systems are what actually make the
difference they would drive the results
and what i've seen
having goals is great having a vision
having a dream is nice it's important to
know where you're going and where you're
headed it's important to have some
clarity of focus to know that we're
moving in this direction but once you
know that having to go on paper makes
very little difference and committing to
the system and showing up every day
drives a lot of results often when we
set about to change something or to
achieve something the first step is
almost always setting a goal uh and this
is coming from someone like i was very
goal-oriented for a long time right like
an asset yeah i was like goals were the
things i wanted to do in sports the
goals the grades i wanted in class the
goals for how much money i wanted to
make in my business
and
sometimes i would achieve those but then
sometimes i wouldn't and so i had this
question like well
clearly i'm setting goals for both so
like that can't be the thing that
determines it and you see this a lot
that the
the winners and losers in a particular
domain often have the same goals like
every olympian wants to win a gold medal
sure
every job candidate wants to get the job
so if the winners and the losers have
the same the same goal then the goal
cannot be the thing that distinguishes
the two
and the thing that distinguishes them is
the process the system behind the goal
this is also important because achieving
a goal often only changes your life for
the moment it's like you know say you're
um
do just take like a simple example say
you have a messy room you know and you
set you get motivated and you set the
goal to clean your room well you can do
that in an hour and then you have a
clean room but if you don't change the
sloppy habits that led to a messy room
in the first place then you just end up
with a dirty room again yeah so it's
like treating a symptom without treating
the cause
and um habits are a better solution in
that case because if you fix the inputs
the outputs fix themselves automatically
right you don't have to fight
to have a clean room if you have clean
habits
and i think that's true in a larger
sense as well right people want outcomes
they want to earn more money or lose
weight or be more productive or reduce
stress but the outcome is not the thing
that needs to change it's the system
that precedes it i remember thinking the
same thing i played baseball all the way
through college and
you know like many sports we had this
kind of like hell week in the beginning
we're you know training conditioning and
everything before the season starts
and um
i remember doing that in the morning we
it started at like 6 a.m and then you
know we got done and i was in class at
like you know nine or something and we
had a test and everybody was freaking
out and i was like this is so stupid to
be worried about this like what i just
did to my body two hours ago or three
hours ago was so much harder than
whatever this quiz is going to be
it just helps like recalibrate your mind
a little bit i think that's one reason
you know i mean i've spent the last
couple years writing about habits and
thinking about the stuff researching the
science like really working mentally
difficultly but what i've noticed is
that i need the physical outlet too
because i don't think that you
if you only push yourself mentally i
don't think you get the full effect um i
think you need both and there's
something about pushing yourself
physically that strengthens yourself
mentally and also helps you just keep
perspective and recalibrate on all the
other stuff that you face in life you it
helps you put things in their proper
place you realize that you know most of
the things you're worried about are not
actually that big of a deal about 15
years ago early 2000s british cycling
hires this guy named dave brailsford and
at that point the last like hundred
years
uh british cycling had been incredibly
mediocre they had won a single gold
medal back in 1908 they had never won a
tour de france which is the premium race
in cycling the premier race
and
so they uh they hired this guy named
dave brailsford to change that and in
fact at the time they were so mediocre
that when they went to buy a new set of
bikes they're gonna get like 200 from a
top manufacturer in europe they actually
weren't even given quotes from the
manufacturer because they didn't want
other teams to see the british writers
using their gear uh for fair they would
it would hurt sales and uh so they
brought brailsford in and they said
what's your plan for changing this he
said well i believe in this philosophy
that i call the aggregation of marginal
gains the way that he described it is
the one percent improvement in nearly
everything that you do so
they started with a bunch of things that
you would expect a cycling team to start
with so for example they put slightly
lighter tires on the bike they got a
more ergonomic seat for the riders to
sit on they had their outdoor riders
wear indoor racing suits because they
were lighter and more aerodynamic they
had each rider wear a biofeedback sensor
so they could see how they would respond
to training and then adjust it
appropriately for the person
but then they did a bunch of things you
wouldn't expect a cycling team to do so
they split tested different types of
massage gels to see which one led to the
best type of muscle recovery they taught
each other how to wash their hands to
reduce the risk of infection so they
wouldn't get a cold after you know and
get sick
they also figured out the type of pillow
that led to the best night's sleep for
each rider and then brought that on the
road with them to hotels uh whenever
they were competing and brailsford said
if we can actually do this right if we
can execute all these little one percent
improvements then i think we can win a
tour de france within five years
he ended up being wrong they wanted in
two years and then they repeated again
the third year with a different rider
and then after one year break they won
two more so they won four out of last
five now i've gone to british cyclists
but it was at the olympics in london in
2012 when this kind of strategy really
came to fruition they won 70 of the gold
medals available
and so
this idea that small improvements tiny
habits little choices are not just a
cherry on top of our performance not
just like a nice thing to have but
actually can be the key that unlocks
significant success that's an idea that
i want us to carry with us as we go
through the rest of this presentation
and one way to think about it is just
kind of basic math like if you just look
at the numbers if you were able to
improve by one percent each day for an
entire year and those gains compound you
would end up 37 times better at the end
of the year and if you were to get one
percent worse you would whittle yourself
almost all the way down to zero
and
what we what's interesting here is that
everybody wants a transformation right
everybody wants a radical improvement we
want rapid success but we fail to
realize that small habits and little
choices are transforming us every day
already that these times when you make a
choice is slightly better slightly worse
a little mistake or a small air
one percent better or one percent worse
that these things compound over time and
habits are the compound interest of
self-improvement
and so if you can learn to master those
then you can make time work for you
rather than get against you right good
habits make time your ally bad habits
make time your enemy people have heard
things like this before start small
small steps whatever but even when you
know you should start small it's still
really easy to start too big so
you know say you want to get in shape
and you're like all right i want to run
a couple days a week but i know i should
start small so i'll only run for 15
minutes but even that is like way bigger
than what i'm talking about i mean it
should be so small that you in the book
i called the two minute rule but you
should down scale any habit to fit
within two minutes so it's like all
right i want to go for a run three days
a week my habit is i put on my running
shoes and i step out the door anything
else that happens after that is just
bonus is a success
now sometimes people resist that because
they're like well this sounds kind of
like a mental trick right like i know
the real goal isn't just to put my shoes
on i know the real goal is to go for a
run so if you feel that way my
suggestion would be
only do the first two minutes for the
first few weeks because what you need to
do is master the art of showing up like
i had a
i had a reader who ended up losing over
100 pounds and one of the things that he
did was he went to the gym but he wasn't
allowed to stay for longer than five
minutes so he would show up be there do
like half an exercise five minutes ago
he'd leave he did this for like six
weeks wow now
it sounds ridiculous it sounds silly
because the odds just work out for a
half hour yeah yeah but what he was
doing was mastering the art of showing
up and a habit must be established
before it can be improved right if you
don't establish the habit there's
nothing to optimize if you're not
showing up at the gym every day you
don't even who cares about what workout
you're doing you're not even there don't
start running an hour a day if you've
never run in a long time be the person
who shows up and puts their running
shoes on every day before you worry
about how far you're running what kind
of workout you're doing and all that
type of stuff there's this thing called
goodheart's law that says a measure
ceases to be a good measure when it
becomes the target and so the point is
like imagine you're trying to lose
weight uh if you use the scale as a
measurement as a data point then yeah it
can be useful as like one signal into
your overall health but if it becomes
the target if the whole mission of
getting in shape becomes about making
the scale go lower well then you start
doing a lot of unhealthy things just to
get the scale to move um you know you
may sacrifice may do some crazy juice
cleanse or some kind of radical diet or
um you end up doing unhealthy things in
the name of moving the number and i
think that there's a lot of application
of that in creativity and business as
well if the number becomes the target
then uh you kind of lose sight of the
bigger picture and so i i feel like i
try to remind myself that measurements
are just a
a piece of the larger puzzle and i can
use them to inform and make sure i'm
moving in the right direction but don't
spend too much time obsessing over any
individual metric
why is something rewarding why do you
find it rewarding and one of the reasons
is because it satisfies the craving that
preceded the action
so
one way to put this is that perceived
value motivates you to act actual value
motivates you to repeat so
it when you buy something on amazon
you don't actually buy the product like
you don't you don't buy the book because
you don't actually have it yet what you
buy is the image the product creates in
your mind you buy your expectation or
the perceived value of the sales page
it's only after you get the book and you
read it and you're like oh this is
really good that's when the actual value
it satisfies that craving you had before
and it reinforces oh hey this was
enjoyable i should do it again next time
so you kind of have both of those on on
each side of the the behavior social
norms society leans heavily on us all
so uh if you
they're just broad examples of this so
pressure religious pressure media
pressure all kinds of steer pressure yes
um
let's say so just some broad examples uh
you walk into an elevator and you turn
around to face the front
you have a job interview and you wear a
suit and tie or a dress or something
nice
there's no reason it has to be that way
right like you could face the back of
the elevator you could wear a swimsuit
to a job interview but you don't do that
because it violates the shared norms of
the group right it violates the shared
expectations of what that society has
but that's not that's true not only in a
broad sense that we're part of these
tribes like big tribes you know what it
means to be a christian or to be
american or to be australian or whatever
but it's also true in the small tribes
that we belong to what it means to be a
neighbor on this street or a member of
your local crossfit gym or to volunteer
for a local organization
all of those tribes all those groups
that you belong to have a set of shared
expectations a set of shared norms
and the key if you want to build habits
that last if you want to change the way
that you interpret cues
is to join a group where your the
desired behavior is the normal behavior
right like there are
there are plenty of people who they want
to work out but going to the gym feels
like a lot to them it feels hard feels
like sacrifice
but there are also people who go to the
gym every week and it's just normal it
doesn't feel like an obligation that's
the desire behavior is the normal
behavior their lifestyle right same
thing for uh musicians you know like if
you want to learn an instrument hang out
with people who play all the time you
know like if you hang out with a bunch
of musicians it's like
yeah we play four days a week if we play
we do well
seven days a week because it just
happens that's that's what the tribe
does
the caveat to this and the thing that i
don't see people mention a lot is that
the reason social norms influence our
behavior so much is because we want to
belong to the tribe we want to be
friends with those people and so we
don't want to lose the friendship or
lose belonging over violating the norms
you're not going to hang out with a
bunch of vegans and have pork
right and just like be the only one
eating that you won't hang out with them
for very long because they're not going
to be friends with them anymore they'll
kick you out so you want to rise to the
standard of that group of that community
so the key i think is to join a group
where your desired behavior is a normal
behavior and you already have something
else in common with that group so uh
steve cam is a good example of this so
like steve runs nerd fitness right and
all these people want to get in shape
who are coming into his community but
they also love star wars or batman or
spider-man or you know all these other
things that nerds are into
and if you show up it can be
intimidating to want to get in shape or
you know work out the first time but if
you can connect with the group over your
mutual love of star wars then you're
like oh well i'm friends with these
people and now i also want to pick up
those other habits with them because i
want to belong with the group because
we're already friends and so i think you
can apply that methodology to most um
new tribes that you join don't just join
a new tribe because they have the
desired behavior also try to find a way
that you can overlap with them find some
shared context some other stuff too yeah
that you can bond over and then it's
easier to adopt musicians that like to
be healthy yeah but if you want to do
both right sure finding that even sub
group it's like hey we love you know we
love playing music and then also you're
going to start eating better because we
all want to eat healthy exactly yeah
this is coming from someone who's been
very goal-oriented for a long time so i
would set goals for the grades i wanted
to get in school or the weights i wanted
to lift in the gym or the amount of
revenue i wanted my business or how many
email subscribers i wanted like all of
that
and
at some point i realized you know i'm
setting all these goals like am i
actually achieving some of them and
sometimes i would but there were plenty
of times where i failed and so i had
this realization that well if that's the
case then setting a goal cannot be the
thing that means whether or not i
achieve success and if you think about
this
the winners and losers in any domain a
lot of the time they have the same goals
you know like every person who applies
for a job has the goal of getting the
job um every olympian has the goal of
winning the gold medal and so if winners
and losers have the same goals then the
goal can't be the thing that makes the
difference
and i don't mean that goals are useless
i think goals are actually quite useful
for setting a sense of direction or
knowing um you know which basically what
area the the boat should be pointed in
what direction the boat should point in
where you're trying to row
but once you've decided that it's
probably more useful to put the goal on
the shelf and focus exclusively on the
system or the process and um in my
language habits make up the system and
they're like this collection of
behaviors and patterns that you perform
each day and when you put them all
together you end up with this system
that delivers a result and
whatever your results are in life or in
business or wherever your current system
is perfectly designed to deliver them it
has to be by definition that's why
you're getting those results so if you
want different results what you need is
not really a different goal we need it's
a different system this is one of the
most common uh i guess criticisms or
complaints that people ask me about with
habits is like well you know i don't
want to be robotic right like what about
like spontaneity what about the you know
freedom and doing what i want you know i
don't want to like pigeonhole myself in
this lifestyle
but uh it's this false dichotomy because
habits don't restrict freedom they
create it you know it's often the people
who have the worst habits that have the
least amount of freedom it's the people
who have terrible financial habits that
are always wondering like where the next
dollar will come from or it's the people
who have poor learning habits that are
always one like feeling like they're
behind the curve um or people who have
poor fitness habits that are always
struggling to find energy but
on the other hand if you have your
habits dialed in if you like you know
have your your fitness habits figured
out if you've got your finances handled
then you actually have way more freedom
than you did before now you actually
have the space to you have the energy to
do what you want you have the strength
to do what you want you have the
financial ability to spend time in areas
that you want um
and all of that comes from getting your
habits handled so it's it's uh
it is a little counterintuitive this
idea that like discipline equals freedom
or habits do not restrict freedom they
create it but it's it's true that if you
can handle that stuff if the
fundamentals of life are dialed in then
you've got space for spontaneity and
creativity and freedom and all the other
stuff in a sense you could say that
every behavior is driven by the desire
for a change in state and so when you
smoke a cigarette or eat a bag of
doritos or pick up your phone what you
really want is not the
nicotine or the calories from the
doritos or the um
the likes on social media what you want
is
to feel less anxious or to feel approved
or to
not be bored anymore so it's really the
desire to change that state that you're
in that motivates you to act and the
behavior and in many cases a lot of our
modern technology is an example of this
you didn't
we didn't evolve you didn't come out of
the womb with like a desire to check
instagram right like there's nothing
evolutionarily wired there it's just a
modern manifestation of an ancient
desire to
gain respect and approval or to not be
abandoned by the tribe or to feel
approved and you know in some capacity
and uh so we kind of have those like
deeper primal drives and then the
secondary layer on top of it is just the
modern manifestation of that behavior
and how we're resolving it in the moment
the first stage of every habit is a cue
the second stage is a craving or some
kind of prediction that your brain makes
i'll give you an example of these in a
second
the third stage is the response and then
the fourth stage is the reward
so
you walk into a the question i had that
that no model i could find could solve
in in any good way or explain in any
good way was why can the same person
respond to the same cue in a different
way so let's say you get into the habit
of going to the gym at five o'clock
every day but then sometimes work gets
busy and you don't go to the gym at five
o'clock current models don't explain
that very well because it's like well
the queue is five you should be going to
the gym right now it says you the
routine falls automatically after the
queue
or
why
why does someone
walk into the kitchen and see a plate of
cookies and then they automatically want
to eat it but you could just as imagine
just as easily imagine that you just got
done eating dinner in the other room and
you're stuffed and you're full and you
walk in you see a plate of coke and
you're like i'm stuffed i don't want to
eat anything so what's going on there
and i think these four stages explain it
which is
you see the cue or you experience a cue
and then your craving or your prediction
differs based on your current state so
the way that you interpret the cues in
your life is contingent upon the current
state that you're in the way you're
feeling right
and also other things like your beliefs
or your identity the social group that
you're part of right so like if you're
in a different group then maybe you
interpret things in a different way
you know you can imagine one group they
practice a particular religion they walk
into a butcher shop and see pork and
they don't they're like oh we can't eat
that right another person walks in and
they're like oh yeah a pork sandwich
because it's obvious and easy and right
there um so
what you choose is contingent upon how
you interpret the cues in your life it's
this idea between the system and the
goal and
you know like say you're you're playing
a sport in every sport the goal is to
have the best score on the scoreboard at
the end of the game but it would be
ridiculous to spend all game looking at
the scoreboard because it wouldn't help
you in any way so in fact if you just
ignored the score the entire time and
just focused on a better process or
playing a better way or a better scheme
or strategy
then you probably would end up with the
best score um i think bill walsh was the
super bowl winning head coach for the
san francisco 49ers he had this quote it
was like the score takes care of itself
and that i think that probably applies
to a lot of tracking and measurement
there are a couple ways to think about
it but i would say just quick definition
a habit is a behavior that has been
repeated enough times to be performed
more or less automatically so you can do
it pretty much on autopilot
but another way to think about it i
think this is a useful way to define a
habit is that
as you go through life you face
different problems and some of those
problems are big and some of them are
small like you need to tie your shoes
and whenever you face a problem your
brain starts looking for solutions to
that and as you come across solutions to
the recurring problems in life
you start to automate those and so every
morning you wake up and you put your
shoes on and you've got this little
problem that you need to solve and
pretty soon after you tie your shoes 100
times or 500 times or a thousand times
you can do it pretty much without
thinking
and so that's another way of thinking
about habits is that they're kind of
these like automatic solutions we fall
into for whatever the recurring problems
are we face right behavior that becomes
habituated yeah and you know like there
the interesting thing about this is you
don't necessarily have to have the same
habit to solve a recurring problem like
if you come home from work each day and
you feel stressed and exhausted one
person might
play video games for an hour and that's
a way to resolve that problem so they
get in the habit of doing it they just
walk over the controller they don't
think about it another person might go
for a run for 20 minutes or meditate for
10 minutes third person might smoke a
cigarette and all of those are just
solutions to that problem that you're
facing and
that i think is another powerful lesson
is that your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal one and once you
realize that then it kind of becomes
your responsibility to
become a little more aware of what those
habits are and then think about can you
shape them or design them right
so in a sense
habits are the path through which you
can reshape your self-image because if
you
this is one reason why i believe in
small habits you know if you um save a
really crazy day at work and you don't
have time to do a full workout well
doing five push-ups it's easy to like
dismiss that and be like well that's not
going to do anything it doesn't get me
in shape but if you do five push-ups
then you reinforce you cast a vote for
the identity of i'm the type of person
who doesn't miss workouts even if it
wasn't ideal even if i didn't have much
time
even if the best i could do after this
12-hour flight was to do five push-ups
and then crash in the hotel bed um
i still didn't miss a workout and
the cumulative effect of that of
reinforcing your desired identity i
think is really big in the long run and
if it's if it's meaningful then it
actually is big even if the action is
small and so that's one reason i believe
in small habits is that they are the
pathway through which you can like
reshape your self-image and um that i
think is the real reason habits matter
it's true they can like habits can help
you get in shape or be more productive
or
reduce stress or make more money and all
those external results are great but the
real thing that they do is they
reinforce and embody the identity of the
type of person that you want to be
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there